Moin, hallo Leute, spontaner Streben, vielleicht sollte ich mein Glas hier nicht hinstellen,
wo das Mauskabel ist, das könnte gefährlich werden, Wonka Shake.
Irgendwie zeigt mir mein Twitch nichts an, was ist da los?
Okay, Sound ist synchron, das muss ich gerade nochmal nachgucken, man weiß ja nie.
Guck mal, der Jax ist auch am Start.
So, mal gucken, wie lange ich das Game heute aushalte.
Ha, die Dinger können runterfallen?
Moment.
Die Dinger können runterfallen?
Wusste ihr, dass die Dinger runterfallen können?
Das hab ich aber nie gesehen.
Nicht aktiviert, psychologisch, ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich mir nicht einen Better
Twitch TV Abo hole, das kostet ja nicht viel, irgendwie 2 Dollar oder so.
Irgendwie zeigt mein Twitch keine Zuschauer an, was ist da los?
Was ist da los?
Jetzt.
So, auf geht's, heute können wir zusammenspielen, wie gesagt, muss ich eh noch Quickplay machen
bis Level 25, also wer mitspielen will, kann mitspielen.
Wogemer, Quickplay, nein, da muss ich klicken, ich hab voll den Reflex, da zu klicken.
Habt ihr was im Cyber Monday Amazon gekauft, Amazon Cyber Monday Woche, also diesmal war
für mich, 2 Sachen hab ich gekauft, ansonsten war nichts dabei.
Ja, bis 21 Uhr ist eh Schluss, so, warten wir mal ab, was die Leute picken.
Ah, eben war heute anstrengend, ich muss erstmal wieder richtig, richtig hier wieder so rein
finden, in das ganze, du spielst wieder Overwatch, ja, seit ich hab mir gestern einen neuen Account
gemacht, es kann aber gut sein, Mercy Main by the way, es kann aber gut sein, dass mir
das Game nach 3 Runden ranked wieder so auf den Sack geht, kein Knopf bei Max, ja, gibt's
doch nicht, also ich, diese Affiliate Geschichte will ich gar nicht machen, also wenn schon,
dann warte ich bis ich konstant Viewer hab und dann mach ich Twitch Partner, weich mach,
dann gibt's nämlich auch ordentlich Emotes und alles, bei Affiliate ist ja so light alles
irgendwie, aber irgendwie hab ich so eine scheiß Haltung gerade, dass ich überhaupt
nicht richtig die Maus bewegen kann, ordentlich hinsetzen.
Und ich brauch mal ein neues Mousepad, ich hab von, ich hab hier ein Rocket Hero, wo
Rocket am Anfang gesagt hat, das kriegst du nie kaputt, soll ich euch mal was sagen,
was das Problem ist, warum ich ein neues brauche, es ist kaputt, lol, warte, Moment, warum
hat es nicht an mir gesaugt, ich geb mir kein Charge, kein Charge für den Max, auf
den Max
Gleich
Hallo, wo tock jetzt habe ich ihn hier angeklickt ich muss erst mal aufwachen ich mache game sound gleich leiser zu laut mache ich mache ich
Game sound leiser
ist jetzt besser
Okay, ich bin so kaputt noch ich brauche jetzt bestimmt erst mal zwei drei runden bis ich halbwegs wach bin
Siehst du warum habe ich da kein schild gedrückt max warum habe ich da kein schild gedrückt
Was soll das hätte ich ins den schild drücken müssen jetzt aber
No, hast du hast du das mit tippe stream mitgekriegt nee wieso was ist da
Was ist was ist was ist mit tippe stream
Was ist mit tippe stream
Was ich gemacht habe da ich so kaputt ich habe keine arbeit bis eben
Den holen wir uns
Wo ist oh alter gibt es doch nicht der payload juckt kein
Okay, ich haue ab
Hallo des des des engage
Ich muss erst mal aufwachen richtig schlimm
Gibt es in overwatch viele cheater gar nicht gar nicht also man sieht da dran sage ja solo
Gar nicht gibt in overwatch quasi keine cheater
Was xml in was für ein injection übers nachrichtenfeld muss man gleich mal durchlesen den tippe stream
Der solcher möchte verrecken oder kann man das nicht kann man das nicht löschen
Ich bin voll verwirrt
Wollte nicht zurück
Ich vergesse meine raketen warum vergesse ich immer meine raketen
Ich vergesse meine raketen ich darf meine raketen nicht vergessen war viel mehr damage
Meist
Ich muss weg, das klappt ja hier gar nix.
Ich verstehe das nicht, musste gleich nochmal schreiben, was mit Tippy Stream ist und Injection
und sowas.
Ja, was ist mit dem Link?
Warum kann ich Meuras Kugel nicht fressen?
Oh man.
Was? Page not found? Ihr verwirrt mich gerade.
Wie soll mich denn jemand über den HTML Textfeld hacken?
Sollen das funktionieren?
Das muss ich jetzt mal angucken ob da was dran ist.
Das was in das Feld geschrieben wird ausgeführt.
Ach so du meinst quasi, dass jemand in dem Feld was einträgt und das wird dann...
Hä?
Warte mal Clip Hacker, ok das guck ich mir jetzt mal an.
Hä der führt irgendwie einer's Sound aus.
Jetzt bin ich rausgetappt, jetzt ist Overwatch abgekackt, super.
Ne ich hab jetzt keine Zeit mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Ich mein ich hab donations eh nicht an gerade, das seh ich eh nix, aber...
Also ich wüsste nicht wie das gehen soll, wie irgendjemand mich hacken soll über den HTML Feld.
Zumal es für mich ja mein Browser ist oder so, hä das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Das einzige was ich mir vorstellen könnte was funktionieren kann, also was funktionieren könnte ist...
Wenn jemand in das donation Feld was manipuliertes reinschreibt, was dann mein OBS ausführen würde.
Das könnte sein, also sprich wenn das OBS Zeug verbackt ist, das liegt dann aber nicht an Tippy Stream, sondern das würde dann an OBS liegen.
Wenn quasi jemand in das Feld da was manipuliertes reinschreibt und mein OBS das irgendwie nicht richtig escapt was auch immer und dann da Dinger ausführt.
Das könnte sein.
Ach dieser Kram der die Nachricht vorliest, ja das könnte auch sein.
Ach so, ja das kann natürlich sein.
Dieses, du meinst dieses Text zu Speech Ding?
Ja das könnte sein, wenn dieses Text zu Speech Ding quasi Text passt und das nicht richtig escapt und dann Scheiße baut.
Das kann passieren, ja das kann sein.
Das kann sein.
Übrigens gestern hat noch Lyona Bomber97 donated für 2,30€ und sagt wenn ich im Saarland bin soll ich im Clobos ein Fleischkäse weg kaufen.
Hab ich erst danach gefuttert.
Ja non but happy kannst du machen, bis ich 25 bin kann jeder mitspielen.
Was 2 Lost Soldiers hast du schon mal Android mit Firebase Backend Services programmiert?
Zum Beispiel Firebase Datenbank mäßig, ne hab ich schon nie gemacht.
Was ist das denn da für ein Comp?
Quad DPS Meter.
Egal Quad DPS Meter auf gehts.
Ja Halbkorn hab ich das jetzt ungefähr so erklärt wie du das meintest mit dem Injection.
Wow, TF.
Was ist hier los?
Auf Genji komm her.
Wer stirbt eigentlich hier gerade?
Hallo? Ok wir sterben. Achtung jetzt kommt hier huge ult huge ult.
Krass, perfekt, super gelaufen.
Ok wir machen noch nicht Quad DPS.
Das war da eine Höchstplatzierung, also letzte Season wo wir Placement Matches gemacht haben irgendwie 3900, das war das letzte.
Aber ich hab zuvor ja auch das letzte Mal Season 4 gespielt.
Also ich bin, ich nehm mal gut.
Und der Genji lebt noch.
Meine Raketen, ich vergess immer meine Raketen.
Warum kann man eigentlich das Mäurer Ding nicht fressen?
Was war das?
Zu viel D.Va in your face.
Easy sagte der McCree.
Wie ist dein Battle Tag? Schreib mal deinen Battle Tag in den Chat.
Allerdings dich.
Aber das mit diesem Mono zurück zu kommen, das ist dann wirklich kein Problem von Tippy Stream, sondern von diesem Text to Speech Programm.
Das kann aber echt sein, also das ist theoretisch zumindest möglich, dass mich irgendjemand über den HTML fällt.
Hexor fällt eher nicht.
Sam Fischer ist Dings Abo sehe ich gerade.
Wie heißt er?
Was ist das für ein Channel Sam? Ist das Dings Iron Aids ist das oder?
Dann kann ich Mäurer Kugeln einschnitten.
Was soll das hier?
Bisschen overextendet, kann das sein?
Das Text zu Speak Feature ist ein Feature von Tippy, na das kann dann aber eigentlich auf meinem Rechner nichts ausführen.
Woran programmierst du gerne in deiner Freizeit?
An einem Notiz Programm mit Editor bastel ich gerade ein bisschen rum.
Nicht, dass die Welt noch mehr Editor gebraucht hätte oder so.
Vor an die Schriegruppen.
Das war keine gute Old.
Tippy hatte getwittert, dass sie einen Bug hatten und ihn gefixt haben.
Kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ein Text zu Speech Feature auf Tippy seit dazu führt.
Das bei mir irgendwas ausgeführt.
Jetzt geht es ab.
So jetzt aber.
Ist das er wach?
Hattest du schon Puppe ausprobiert? Puppe ja ist nicht mein Fall.
Achtung Achtung Jungs.
Verreckt auch noch einer dran.
Was jetzt bin ich ausgereicht da unten hingegangen wo die Diva steht da steht nie eine Diva.
Nee oder.
Also Puppe ist nicht mein Fall.
Puppe ist nicht so meins.
Ich weiß auch nicht das an sich.
Ich habe halt ein Problem gegen Spiele die nicht richtig funktionieren.
Ich ich ich bin da ich habe da glaube ich zu wenig.
Ich habe da irgendwie zu wenig Toleranz irgendwie für so für Games die sich so unfertig und kaputt anfühlen.
Gegen das Spiel Prinzip von Puppe habe ich gar nichts.
Aber Puppe fühlt sich halt.
So.
Anpolished an einfach so.
So unfertig.
Und es gibt Spiele die sind auch in der Beta schon rund.
Oder runter.
Zumal ist ist Puppe jetzt nicht sogar offiziell raus.
Sollte das nicht offiziell jetzt rauskommen.
Sollte Puppe nicht erscheinen jetzt.
Mir fällt es echt schwer zu streben nach der Arbeit.
Irgendwie so kaputt.
Soll jetzt Ende des Jahres kommen.
Na gut da haben sie ja noch einen Monat Zeit.
Aber ich meine das Game ist jetzt nicht fertig.
Warum sollte es in einem Monat wenn es dann quasi in Anführungsstrichen offiziell erscheinen fertig sein.
Oh 2CP jawoll.
Endlich ich habe mich schon drauf gefreut.
Waren wir die erste 2CP Map spielen dürfen.
17. Dezember.
Irgendwie das Problem ist so bei vielen Early Access Spielen.
Die haben das ist genau das Gegenteil finde ich.
Wie es bei manchen AAA Spielen ist.
Bei manchen AAA Spielen habe ich das Gefühl.
Man macht das einfach nur weil man jetzt mal wieder was machen muss.
Dafür ist die technische Umsetzung meistens ganz okay.
Und viele Early Access Spiele haben eigentlich grundlegend eine ganz gute Idee.
Aber die technische Umsetzung ist oft mal scheiße.
Und wird auch nicht fertig.
Und die beste Idee bringt einem nichts wenn die Umsetzung komplett für den Arsch ist.
Was spielen wir denn hier?
Da da da da.
Ja was soll ich denn?
Keine Ahnung.
Wo ist er?
TooLostSoldiers frage woran ich heute gearbeitet habe.
Ich habe ganz viele Sachen.
Ganz viele Fixes für unsere aktuelle Software, für unser aktuelles Release.
Getchari picked.
Unter anderem.
Und geklärt warum da was ist und wie da was ist.
Und was da nicht kaputt geht und solche Dinge.
Diese Moira Kugel nervt.
McCree!
McCree ist der ist echt lebensmütiger Typ.
Ich sollte da nicht hinterher rennen.
War total bescheuert dem Genji jetzt hinterher zu rennen.
Beschäftigst du dich mit Paisen?
Selten mache ich was.
Bist du IT-Chef deiner Firma?
Nein.
Wo sind denn hier überhaupt Gegner?
Da oben!
Da kann ich jetzt als Orissa aber doch nicht hin.
Ich bin langsam.
Bestes Schild!
Aller Zeiten.
Leute ich kann nicht.
Ich glaube ich mache aus.
Kann ich spielen heute.
Ich bin total brain afk.
Ich realisiere kaum wo Gegner sind.
Hast du schon mal das MMO gezockt was der Frisör 24 in spielt?
Ja hab ich.
Hab da sogar nen Level 59er Wizard der ganz gut ausgerüstet ist.
Was macht ihr für Software?
Finanzkram.
Ich meine warum stehe ich hier rum?
Das ist einfach total dumm.
Was mache ich denn hier überhaupt?
Was ist das für eine Arsch?
Komplett nicht bei der Sache.
Scheiß drauf.
Ich muss jetzt switchen.
Orissa Adamin ist der Punkt verloren.
Guck mal warum habe ich nicht gleich rechts geklickt?
Ich bin so schlecht heute.
Ich habe das Gefühl das Gehirn lag von 3 Sekunden.
Ich komme überhaupt nicht rein.
Warum habe ich nicht direkt rechts geklickt?
So wird das nichts.
Im Fischer sucht man ein nächstes Game.
Das ist nur Quickplay.
Das Problem ist ich kann nicht komplett Gehirn afk spielen.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Da ist mein eigener Anspruch zu hoch.
Das gute Input lag.
Ich merke das richtig.
Nach Tagen wo ich gearbeitet habe und abends noch irgendwie spielen will.
Ich bin null fokussiert und kriege auch nur die Hälfte mit.
Ich habe nur einen Account gemacht weil ich viel zu hoch gerankt bin mit meinem anderen.
Zumindest für das wie ich gerade spiele.
Das ist ich weil ich merken kann dass ich mehr fokussiert bei der Sache bin.
Es sah ja einen Schnitt verkehrt.
Zum Glück ist es erst 25.
Ich weiß nicht woran das liegt.
Ich habe es schon öfters gemerkt wenn ich etwas ernsthaft spielen will.
Oder allgemein etwas ernsthaft machen will wo man sich konzentrieren muss nach dem arbeiten.
Ich kriege das einfach nicht hin.
Ich spiele voll langsam und alles klappt einfach nicht.
Das Schlimme ist ich merke das ist nicht nur im Game.
Ich merke auch dass ich total faul bin und manchmal die Maus gar nicht bewegen will.
Also wenn da jetzt ein Gegner ist und ich ziele jetzt dahin.
Dann mache ich lieber so bis ich drüber bin anstatt so.
Ich bin ja total bescheuert obwohl es viel schlechter ist und viel langsamer.
Einfach weil ich faul wie Sau bin an so einem Tag.
Ach man kann ja jetzt heilen wenn man.
Aber wir gehen jetzt einfach rein.
Das klappt so nicht.
Das ist ja das war früher nicht so schlimm.
Früher war ich unter der Woche ich keine Ahnung Schule aber vor ein Schwur.
Da war ich danach noch 5 bis 22 Uhr überhaupt kein Ding.
Jetzt bin ich so voll voll weggetreten irgendwie.
Wochenende und so vor allem wenn ich ausgeschlafen habe ist kein Problem.
Ich merke warum habe ich den Hook jetzt nicht getroffen.
Das war das einfachste Tag aller Zeiten.
Und warum laufe ich hier alleine rein und warum kommt keiner mit.
Das liegt nicht nur daran weil es Quickplay ist.
Das liegt einfach daran weil ich zacke wie Sau gerade.
Aber richtig.
Und jetzt habe ich auch das Problem dass ich jetzt gar nicht weiß was nehmen soll.
Es ist mir früher alles nicht passiert.
Da habe ich Tab gemacht war instant klar was gepickt werden muss alles gut.
Vielleicht sollte ich wirklich bloß noch Wochenende spielen und streamen.
Beziehungsweise spielen im Stream und unter der Woche etwas anderes machen.
Streamtechnisch.
Moment hatten die gerade ein Gegner zu wenig.
Ich war gerade sogar zu faul um mich umzudrehen.
Was.
Hoverhand sage.
Was war das jetzt gerade für ein Game.
Die Maus nicht richtig bewegen will dass ich immer nur so kleine kleine Sachen so kleine Bewegungen mit der Maus mache weil ich sie nicht bewegen will.
Normalerweise musste ihr halt einfach mal zack da bist du auch beim Genji hinterher.
Ja Singleplayer wäre wahrscheinlich besser.
Aber was.
Keiner Call of Duty das halte ich nicht aus.
Ich muss ich muss euch das mal kurz zeigen.
Ich gehe mal kurz Training.
Das ist wirklich ganz ganz schlimm.
Das Problem hatte ich früher nicht.
Normalerweise.
Normalerweise wenn ich den jetzt treffen will.
Dann jetzt würde ich irgendwie sowas hier machen.
Ich würde quasi meine Maus minimal bewegen wird so machen.
Und wenn da oben eines normalerweise musste halt wenn Genji an dir vorbei das macht halt den da.
Da zieht man macht seine Maus rüber.
Aber nee ich mache sowas hier sowas.
Was ist das hier.
Wie beschissen kann man sein.
Warum mache ich sowas anstatt hier einfach mal die Maus ordentlich rüber zu schieben.
Oder anstatt.
Ich ich lieber wie der letzte anstatt hier einfach mal rüber zu zielen und sowas.
Ich bin einfach mega faul.
Und da kann das auch nichts werden.
Ist wirklich so.
Das mache ich gar nicht.
Obwohl ich weiß Genji ist jetzt an der Seite würde ich niemals hier den da machen.
Weil es wird so anstrengend ist einmal was Mauspads zu fahren.
Ist halt beknackt.
Vielleicht muss ich einfach mal was futtern.
Ich hole mal was zu essen vielleicht wird es dann besser.
Sam Fischer ich spiele mal eine Runde alleine kurz.
Social Eating.
Ja klar.
So lange wie ich will ist das gut.
Für immer garantiert nicht.
Für immer nicht.
Aber so ein paar hundert Jahre oder so.
So mal gucken wie sich das alles entwickelt.
Da wäre ich dabei.
Ja.
Vielleicht sollte ich besser wirklich besser auf Singleplayer Games umschwenken unter
der Woche.
Einfach zu im Arsch.
Gibt es hier irgendwelche super super Tricks die man mit Orisa machen kann.
So nach dem Motto an der Ecke warten hier hinschießen.
Zweieinhalb Komma 5 3 2 1 Sekunden warten und dann schießen oder sowas gibt es bestimmt.
5 Prozent.
Das Mäurer perfekte Pose da vorne.
Hier gibt es nicht.
Das hier wieder bleibt mir gar nichts anderes übrig.
Wir irgendwie keine Ahnung soll schon sonst was zu spielen.
Was soll das ja das kenne ich noch.
Links flenkt irgendwas rum.
Nein.
Aber ich habe es noch mehr.
Gut dass der Genji reingesprungen ist.
Hanzo Hanzo Hanzo.
Das ist schon wieder alle tot.
Ich warte mal auf meine Leute.
Das geht mit Blitz ab.
Ich muss High Ground und dann wird reingeholtet.
Kann er sich bei Muten der Typ auf.
Eigentlich wäre es viel besser ich laufe hinten rum.
Egal.
Hast du einen 144 Scherz Monitor.
Ja habe ich.
Außerdem springe ich zu viel mit Zaulscher.
Ich muss mir das veräven.
Das Schlimme ist wenn man weiß was man verkehrt macht und es trotzdem nicht macht.
Ich muss den Typ muten.
Der nervt mir wie mutet man überhaupt Leute.
Auf Bum Bum Bum.
Ich treffe nichts.
Komm mal her ich heile dich Hanzo.
Hanzo ich heile dich.
Komm mal her.
Ich könnte jetzt mal nach oben gehen.
Der Hanzo.
Ach das stört mich nicht das 55 für ab.
Das ist ja auch gerade zum einschlafen.
Okay die haben.
Sniper.
Was ist denn hier rechts los.
Oh.
Na super.
Geh wir kontest nicht.
Oh ich bin so im Arsch.
Ich kann nicht spielen.
Ich kann das eigentlich.
Kann ich mich jetzt hinsetzen.
Irgendwelche YouTube Videos.
Gucken wir das war's.
Ich glaube mit Multiplayer.
Extrem sondern eine Woche.
Das lasse ich bleiben.
Wahrscheinlich ist er frei.
Nein.
29 Prozent.
Lohl.
Signing Stream.
Ich habe hier erst gelesen.
Singing Stream.
Aber vorhin hat hier jemand gekriegt.
Signing Stream.
So Schleeting Stream war ich ja schon gerade.
Ich werde nicht heiraten.
Ich verstehe den Sinn von heiraten.
Ne nicht.
Wo die Chancen sehr hoch sind.
Statistisch gesehen.
Und jeder denkt natürlich aber mir passiert das nicht.
Ja weniger Steuern.
Aber also alleine wegen den Steuern zu heiraten ist ja schon mal das erste Problem.
Also der erste Fail.
Und wenn das mal in die Hose geht.
Dann bist du mehr Kohle.
Vor allem wenn du noch Kinder in die Welt gesetzt hast in der Zeit.
Dann bist du ja mehr Kohle los.
Als du da jemals gespart hast mit Steuern.
Und wie gesagt die Chancen sind gar nicht so.
Statistisch gesehen.
Nicht wirklich gering.
Ich weiß nicht wie viele Ehen heute geschieden werden.
Aber ich gehe mal davon aus wir sind locker schon bei jeder zweite.
Ja gut zusammen wohnen kann man machen.
Solange man.
Also man muss ja dafür nicht heiraten.
Das spricht ja nichts dagegen.
Hey wie gefällt mir das Charakter Design von Moira nicht.
Mal reu dich aus.
So spammen wir mal dahinter.
Oh Max jetzt sei mal nicht so faul mit deiner Maus Bewegung.
Alter was ist denn hier los.
Ich bin doch keine 80.
Warum sterben die schon alle hier wieder mit.
Danke danke.
Danke.
Was macht der Typ da vorne.
Komm her Hanzo Hanzo.
Was hat uns da was geflankt oder soll ich da jetzt mit vor das ist einfach beknackt.
Der Spielfluss hier den check ich nicht.
Das wird so.
Was ist das.
Was geht hier.
Keine Ahnung was da abgeht.
Was sind die Games.
Ist die Quote bei gebildeten Menschen wirklich nicht so hoch.
Es kann sein gebildete Menschen überlegen sich wahrscheinlich dreimal ob zu heiraten.
Das soll schilden.
Moment wo sind die Gegner.
Ich kann jetzt einfach mit vor scheint ja gerade voll angesagt zu sein.
Was ist das hört sich an wie so ein.
Wie so ein Kocher.
Die der Zauber von dieser dieser Attack Zauber von Meurer.
Wie so ein Wasser Kocher.
Du bewegst deine Maus nicht ordentlich um Genji zu verfolgen.
Warum hast du hier die die die Spar Variante hier.
Schießt auf mich.
Danke.
Achtung wenn die hier durchkommen ist huge.
Huge Ult machen wir jetzt.
Da kommt keiner durch auch gut.
Ich dachte da kommen jetzt mehr durch.
Aber sie kommen auf einmal mehr durch.
Diese machen das genauso planlos wie wir.
Schieß mich an.
Einmal nicht aufgepasst.
Richtig dumm wieder gewesen.
Richtig hängen geblieben.
Warum treffe ich den Kopf von der Fahrer nicht.
Man weiß es nicht.
Das war ein Rechtsklick oder.
Ich sag euch das war ein Rechtsklick.
Nee war es nicht.
Fühlst du dich manchmal innerlich leer.
Alter was soll das für Fragen.
Heute Mittag habe ich mich innerlich leer gefühlt.
Da war ich bei Fletcher's better Burger danach.
Ich wollte hier 2.0 machen.
Wo ist eigentlich der Paylord.
Da hinten ist der Paylord.
Ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl die Gegner rennen.
Ist das hier so was wie auf der Messe.
Wo man einfach random irgendwas bashen kann.
Also doch habe ich aber ich finde das mit Recoil Anzeige besser.
Ich habe mich Azure eingelötet.
ja wie gesagt innerlich leer hab ich mich heute mittag gefühlt, aber richtig innerlich leer
innerlich leer und dann gab es mir doppelt Fleisch und war ich nicht mehr leer was für
eine erkenntnis die wir brauchen jetzt aber echt philosophisch ich habe jetzt
zusammen apps entwickeln oder erfolgreich werden hast du eine gute idee für ein app hast du richtig richtig krasse idee da kann man drüber reden
fühlst du dich von veganern getriggert
kommt darauf an ob sie es drauf anlegen wenn sie mich in ruhe lassen nicht
und nur weil einer vegan ist juckt mich das auch nicht großartig aber wenn leute
anfangen ein versuchen sie überzeugen dass es alles schlechte ist was man macht
und dass ihr ist das einzig wahre da geht es mir auf den sack
hast du schon ein paar apps entwickelt ich habe überhaupt keine ahnung von android
entwicklung aber kam ja mittlerweile auch mit sie scharf machen da kann ich mir
keine die sprache weil in java werde ich nicht programmieren das das gebe ich mir
nicht heute viewer games ja hatte ich eigentlich vor ich fühle mich gerade
nicht in der lage dem spiel geschehen einigermaßen zu folgen deswegen heute
eher nicht hallo schere nummer eins besser name moment auf geht's winston ja
sonntags von java und sehr scharf sind sie scharf sind relativ ähnlich wobei
java ganz viele merkwürdigen dinger hat weiß ich das sagt mir überhaupt nicht
zu gar nicht außerdem hat java hat java mittlerweile ordentliche generics ich
glaube nicht no plane hey winston ist der beste der beste
hält wenn man ihn kann für leute die mecanik technisch nix drauf haben so
wie ich wenn man kann also nicht so also so macht so macht man zum beispiel das
mit winston nicht so macht man das nicht malerweise sprich zu rein und dann war
es zu wissen ob wir es dann warst du babbel und so nicht und fallen weg
schon mal gar nicht muss als winston muss immer drauf immer drauf
und tschüss zu
please brauche brauche auto alter der junkrat der nervt
offer was kurz tips da am wochenende wieder
blub blub
achtung die schmeißen jetzt hier runter klein
hat nicht so ganz funktioniert
ich weiß dass man ohne wegsporn ich weiß das sollst du mich übelst
warum habe ich nicht einfach kugel drückt als versuch darauf zu schießen
wenn es ist als
die neue mercy eigentlich gut oder scheiße ich habe die ich kenne nur die ganz alte mercy
noch wie gesagt diesen vier war das letzte wo ich ordentlich gespielt habe ich kenne
es halt nur aus streams quasi mit bei ult quasi zweimal instant reds und ein must
have und weil halt tempo das was ich jetzt gesehen habe ist glaube ich die
neue mercy hatte so ein timer beim reds ich könnte mir aber vorstellen dass
moira mercy eine gute kombi ist die wir auf turnieren sehen werden
weil tempo reds ist immer noch eigentlich das entscheidende also sprich
du kämpfst einer stirbt von dir mercy kann wiederbeleben da bist du einfach instant einer
mehr
lull
Oh ne, ne ne, da kann ich, da kann ich nicht pieken
LOL
Es ist hier wieder das Spawn-Rape angesagt
flop rock
Was man hier immer alleine will, das hele goat
Ne, was spürt Ihr 밖에 mein, ist haltordin Greece
Du kämpfst, es stirbt bei dir einer und du wirst ja bei dem Weit
auch jemand killen selten das komplette weib ist wo keiner stirbt vom anderen team und du
kannst wiederbeleben da bist du hast du den instant wieder einen mehr und du musst nichts
dafür machen außer außer der tasse drücken beim was sie das ist das was ich meine
nichts gerissen carried get carried nonbad happy einfach üben ist leichter gesagt als getan
wichtig ist finde ich dass man selbst mit sich unzufrieden ist und selbst merkt wenn man scheiße
baut auch wenn es wenn es echt frustrierend ist also quasi das was mir alle fünf sekunden aktuell
auffällt manchmal bin ich da auch so über kritisch aber kacke spielen nervt mich also
kacke spielen nervt mich selbst glaube ich am meisten und man selbst sieht ja auch noch viel mehr
bei deinem team jetzt ist es ja nur von außen aber wenn du selbst spielst ist ja viel mehr was
du für eine scheiße baut welche helden müssen da immer mal noch gebufft werden kann ich nichts
zu sagen ich muss erst mal wieder in das game reinkommen und wieder ein bisschen
eng spielen und alles wobei gebufft was haben wir da also sachen was halt aktuell was halt
überhaupt nicht gespielt wird zum etwa muss beispielsweise nicht gebufft werden ist
situationsabhängig vielleicht ein bisschen aber situationsabhängige helden sind ok
mei zum beispiel wird halt relativ wenig gespielt ana müssen wir mal gucken ich finde der rest kann
im großen und ganzen so bleiben es soll man muss halt die helden nicht immer komplett auf
den auf den kopf stellen murci sollte finde ich grundlegend dahingehend überarbeitet werden
dass wenn es dann ebenso stark ist dass dazu auch ein bisschen was gehört also dass man nicht klar
murci ist jetzt nicht super easy quasi so absolut no brain aber es gibt quasi kaum den anderen
hält der solo er ist aber hier nicht wir brauchen irgendwas was ein bisschen mobility hat
winston ist super winston ist top was willst du an winston nerven
winston ist doch gut winston ist der beste char wenn man was nicht drauf hat
im technisch und sonst was und trotzdem viel reißen will winston counter tracer frage eigentlich
wenn man ehrlich ist klar so sowas wie rotor geht natürlich aber eigentlich nix nix so richtig
was machen die da vorne stelle mich jetzt einfach mal eben halt der rechte klick und ich gebe da
den holen war habe ich einen rotor gehört
ich finde winston und tracer das ist das das geht bei dass du kannst auch als tracer den winston
relativ schnell kaputt machen wenn das gut spielt was hältst du von rocket league also
vom game habe ich ich habe sie gespielt blöd das klingen was kann man jetzt mal machen das
läuft kratz sogar moment haben wir noch nie hier haben wir
das ist wirklich auf auf dem aufsteigenden ast
also ich habe jetzt viele sachen schon gesehen wo rocket league gespielt wird
oh ich hatte kein momento mehr ups ups so viel wieder zum thema planer afrika
over extension of doom
ja das neue gott auf dem pc ist auch komisch
recht
hat
wird
mal
machen
Wo ist der hässliche Sniper?
Oben rechts, oder?
Ja, World War 2 hat auf dem PC ziemliches Input-Lag und es ist voll mit Cheatern mittlerweile schon. Schrecklich.
Ich werde gleich mal abhauen.
Nee, mach ich nicht.
Kill mich, please.
Was killt mich halt?
Ah.
Was macht denn der Reinhard da oben?
Äh, okay. Wir haben gar keinen Heal-Saw mehr.
Okay.
Der Reinhard da oben, beste Position, beste Position.
Fahr mal im Kreis.
Nein, nein, nein. Leute, Leute.
Der Omni-Healer, der ist wirklich weit vorne.
Schon links war es. Ist das unserer?
Fuck.
Okay, das war's. Fast haben wir Old gekriegt.
Was?
Nein, oh Mann.
Ja, richtig Overwatch-Comp und Rank kannst du null vergleichen. Eine Rede.
Ein bisschen Rocket League ist kein Schimmer.
Ja, die Singleplayer-Events vom neuen CoD auf dem PC sind wirklich an die Framerate gebunden. Total lächerlich.
Es gibt Quick-Time-Events im neuen CoD, da hat man hier so einen Kreis und quasi hier irgendwo wird dann die Maus angezeigt und man muss quasi einfach nur den Mauszeiger in den Kreis ziehen.
Und man hat ungefähr, keine Ahnung, ich kann jetzt schlecht die Zeit, so quasi. So viel Zeit hat man. Wie der Heldwechsel jetzt dauert, um das zu machen. Also gar nicht.
Du stellst die Runde, 50 Hertz, Monitor stellst du ein, mit V-Sync-Ersatz, das Spiel quasi auf 50 FPS begrenzt, ist gar kein Ding.
Packt jeder.
Mach mal Werbung. Für den Stream. Ja, das stimmt, es hat kein Appel an, das macht nichts. Das ist nicht so schlimm.
Sei mal gern, weil der andere Account so hoch ist, der Main-Account. Den einen Account weiß ich das Login nicht mehr.
Haha, so dumm es klingt. Weil der andere Account ist ja genauso hoch wie der Main-Account.
Ich habe einen Main-Account und meinen Smurf von damals noch, die sind beide irgendwie jetzt, diesen vier haben wir ja gespielt, irgendwie 3900 gewesen oder so.
Und den anderen weiß ich nicht mehr. Moment, ich dachte man kann schießen, ach nee, schießen mit Matrix geht nicht.
Ach nee, ich habe gar kein Shift da gehabt.
Ich glaube es nicht. Ich glaube es nicht.
Hanzo.
Weiter geht's. Irgendwie habe ich gedacht ich höre was da oben, habe ich aber nicht.
Ah, Widow, LOL. Wir haben keinen Bock zu Moven.
Doch nicht.
Ding ding ding ding ding ding.
Easy.
Hahaha, super, das hast du so gut gemacht, Mixwee. Super, sehr schön.
Direkt, würde ich sagen.
Oh, da gehen wir jetzt hin. Ich lasse mich heilen.
Oh nee.
Ah, fuck. Hätte ich ein bisschen schneller oben gewesen, hätte ich so beide geowned.
Was ist neu, Assassin's Creed hatte ich überrascht. Taugt das?
Ich bin wieder offen.
Mein Baum ist ja nicht gestorben.
Hahaha.
Fuck.
Okay. Ja, das neue Assassin's Creed wollte ich mal eventuell auch mal anschaffen.
Reaper. Oh, oh Achtung, der will ulten, der will ulten.
Was ist das für ein Typ?
Perfekt.
Ich glaube, Mercy wird es weiterhin geben. Ah nee, du hast ja Mercy drin stehen.
Ich bin jetzt wieder weiter gespielt.
Okay.
Mehr killen kann ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerade.
Wieder hüpft.
Die D.Va macht so krass Damage mit den Raketen mittlerweile. Wahnsinn.
Was ist mit deinem zweiten 8700k passiert, habe ich zurückgeschickt.
Habe ich zurückgeschickt.
Und doch wieder Overwatch.
Kommt von Overwatch nicht weg.
Overwatch ist einfach ein geiles Game. Ich sage es jeden Stream 85, 30 Milliarden Mal, wenn der Rank Modus nicht so verkackt wäre.
Dann wäre das das beste Game überhaupt.
Hübschu.
Die D.Va.
Nee, vielleicht anders, Beast Typ.
Und leider fördert Overwatch Rank ganz schön so toxic Geschichten.
Man kann neben dem ganzen Zeug, was ich über Rank erzähle, eines der größten Probleme, die mir damals auch schon auf den Sack gegangen sind.
Wie gesagt, diese vier war das letzte, wo ich so richtig aktiv gespielt habe.
Du kannst die Matches, die wirklich ausgeglichen sind, kannst du an einer Hand abzählen.
20% der Matches sind ausgeglichen. Dann gibt es die Matches, wo drüber gerutscht wird, über einen oder mal über den Gegner.
Die Matches, die von den Stats so aussehen, als ob es knapp gewesen wäre, aber nie knapp waren.
Ich habe jetzt gerade keinen Nerv drauf gehabt.
Ja, Sunkor, Spasten gibt es überall, Toxicrum, Geflaming gibt es auch überall. Überall, wo es Leder gibt, überall, wo es Rank gibt.
Keine Frage.
Es ist die Frage, wie es das auswirkt. Nur rum nerven im Chat.
Und halt sich anstellen. Und in LoL gibt es da ab und zu mal welche, die feeden. Ist alles okay.
Aber in Overwatch hat das System von Trollpicks zu Metra-Mains zu Leuten, die mit One-Trick-Links-Click-Mercy-Quant-Master geworden sind.
Die so nicht mal toxic mime, sind sie ja auch von ihrer Einstellung her nicht.
Aber das fördert das ganze halt noch. Dann rage die Leute, die eh schon so toxic veranlagt sind, noch mehr rum.
Und dazu kommt halt eben, dass die Spiele nicht ausgeglichen sind.
20% der Spiele sind vielleicht ausgeglichen. Der Rest ist aufregend.
Und wenn quasi zu Toxic-Leuten, die es in jedem Spiel gibt, auch in jedem Spiel mit Ranked, ganz klar, wenn dann auch so quasi die Rahmenbedingungen das Ganze noch irgendwie fördern
und dazu führen, dass man... Nein, man könnte ja über die Toxic-Leute hinweg sehen, wenn das Spiel unglaublich geil wäre und Spaß machen würde,
weil alles andere passt, dann wäre das ja überhaupt kein Ding.
Aber das Spiel im Kern ist ja auch geil. All den Rank nicht.
Ha, ha, ha. Two Lost Soldiers. Ja, würde ich mir drüber Gedanken machen.
Würde ich mir drüber Gedanken machen.
Kommt natürlich auch auf die Bezahlung an.
Du weinst, wenn du mit deiner Android-App dann die ersten Millionen gemacht hast.
Two Lost Soldiers.
Monturissa, nicht F.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich als Solo-Tank spielen soll, Winston. Nein. Aber Winston als Solo...
Nein, wir hätten eigentlich genug Heal. Komm. Speed. Oh, wir haben Lucio.
Wieder D.Va. Mir bleibt gar nichts anderes übrig gerade.
Keine Pharah am Start, okay.
Ich habe es gar nicht geschafft, alle Raketen zu verfehlen.
Wollen Sie eine Pharah? Ich brauche mein Auto wieder.
Gibt es nicht.
Ich habe vier DPS abgelenkt. Mehr konnte ich nicht machen.
Das geht auf höherem Rang. Also da hast du auch genug Leute, die Tank spielen. Na, wobei Tank vielleicht weniger. Die, die auch Support spielen.
Ach, also ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, ich finde LoL scheint, ich spiele es nicht, aber LoL scheint ein gutes Ranking-System zu haben.
Kann man regroupen?
Können wir gehen, please?
Alter.
Also das Ranking-System von LoL macht wirklich einen brauchbaren Eindruck.
Reckt.
Oh, falsch, falsch, in die falsche Richtung gesprungen.
Ich brauche mein Auto. Wo ist mein Auto?
Ich brauche mein Auto wieder.
Ich brauche mein Auto.
Und ich finde auch, dass die, wo wir gerade noch bei Ranking so sind, ich finde auch, die Patches sind viel zu langsam.
Da musst du drauf reagieren, nicht wahr? Muss ich das mal angucken? In Dota 2 kriegen sie das ja auch alles hin.
Klar, da gibt es auch Toxic Leute. Klar, da wird auch geflamed.
Klar, da gibt es auch ein Meta. Wobei, dass es ein Meta gibt, ist nichts Schlimmes. Will es immer geben.
Aber es ist alles mal eine Ecke weniger nervig.
Ich bin jetzt D.Va Main. Easy. Mit Null Medaillen. Reckt.
Achtung, die wird jetzt gehauen. Sobald hier einer durchkommt, wird er gebashed.
Nein. Gibt es nicht.
Es war ein bisschen, ein bisschen auf der Externe, ein bisschen, ganz.
Hier ist, hier ist, hier ist.
Ich muss raus.
Nope, Genji, Nope.
Oh nee. Ich meine, das ist gut. Ihr konzentriert euch auf mich. Alles gut.
Moment. Was haben die, haben die eingenommen? Das ist jetzt schlecht.
Jetzt können sie mich auen.
Gibt es nicht.
Nope, Genji ist auch nicht.
Siehst du nicht, wie viel ich habe? Zwei Millionen Abos.
Okay.
Genau.
Ich kaffe dann den Katja Krasna Witse Song mit zwei Millionen Abos.
Der Friseur findet den übelst geil.
So war es auch angemerkt. Also nicht Katja Krasna Witse, keine Ahnung, sondern den Song.
Aber bitte oben ohne. Klar, nackt. Dem Kaboom zusammen. Den Krieger lassen wir auch nackig durchs Bild ran.
Wir haben als erstes zwei Support Picks.
Ich warte mal kurz, was da noch so kommt.
Das schreit so ein bisschen nach Reinhard, aber Reinhard ohne ordentlichen Support ist schwierig.
Komm, scheiß drauf. Ich weiß nicht, mit Warthog. Also mit dem neuen Warthog bin ich noch gar nicht warm geworden und mit Warthog als Solo Tank finde ich es auch immer schwierig.
Einen ordentlichen Tank raus da.
Da ist einer rübergegangen.
Oh, wir haben eine Widow am Start. Ich weiß nicht, wo die ist. Warum mache ich meinen Fire Strike eigentlich gar nicht? Ich will TF.
Kannst ja mal probieren.
Das ist das wichtigste. Und sich nicht killen lassen, nicht killen lassen, nicht killen lassen.
Oh fuck.
Halten wir uns mal.
Eigentlich muss man hier nicht falten.
Jetzt, huge Shatter, huge Shatter.
Muss ich gar nicht Shattern.
Achtung, Trick 17.
Oh, Hexsword.
Hexsword.
So, weg. Nein, warum? Warum hätte ich Genanoboostet?
Oh Mann, das dachte ich mir. Scheiß drauf. Raus jetzt den Shatter raus. Ich meine, es kommt ja eh nix. Und zack, sind sie am Start. Richtig dumm. Ich habe den ewig aufgehoben. Wo wir dann dabei sind, keine Altenwärze loshauen.
Hätte ich ihn aufgehoben, oder? Es war klar, der Genji kommt mit Plate an.
Oh fuck, ich habe kein Schild gehabt. Oh mach die platt. Die ist doch schon tot.
Die Orissa, ja gut.
Ich glaube, links rum ist schneller, oder? Ich glaube, links rum. War links rum nicht schneller?
Bongos.
Hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp, hopp.
Ah, dieser, dieses Ding. Dieses Ding. Was ist das? Das Teil.
Jetzt können wir contesten. Wir haben aber keinen Bock. Kann man contesten? Kann man contesten? Kann man contesten?
Anni.
Ist das ein Pro, Reinhardt?
Dieser Ball, dieser Ball. Der fuckt mich so ab.
So im Rank fährt es das typische Lul-DPS-Sarg-I-have-gold-medal.
Das war so richtig schön toxic-ranked Antwort jetzt.
Tja.
Aber die Balls sind wirklich nervig.
Hansu, du kannst da oben übrigens den Scatter reinhauen, oder?
Ich muss Hilfe. Ich brauche Hilfe.
Nein. Sonst wäre ich eh nicht mehr weggekommen. Fuck.
Was nehmen wir denn mal hier? Reinhardt bringt es ja nicht so wirklich.
Komm, scheiß drauf. Wir bleiben jetzt mal, Reinhardt.
Wir müssen halt mal groupen, sonst bringt das nichts.
Aber die pushen auch nicht. Ist auch gut.
Nee, nee, nee, nee. Keine Chance.
Und testen.
BTF.
Das war eine schöne Combo. Ich glaube zwar irgendwie nicht, dass die Combo absicht war.
Also diese Orissa-Combo.
Alter, das gibt es halt nicht. Kacke. Jetzt rennst du auch noch rein.
Nee, ist da gar nicht so übel gegen.
Gegen die Witter.
Und das sind sie.
Baby D.Va.
Oh, oh.
Was? Warum ist der Hanzo nicht... Nein, nein, ich bin der Falle.
Also wer konnte ich jetzt gefühlt am Schluss wirklich knapp machen?
Es gibt es doch nicht, Alter.
Ohje, Güte.
Was hätte ich da jetzt anders machen sollen? Ich habe überhaupt... Ich habe total den Überblick verloren.
Das hätten wir dreimal gewinnen müssen. Ich habe total den Überblick verloren zwischendurch.
Ich habe zwischendurch... Ich hätte schon mal auf die Widow fliegen können,
aber ich habe zwischendurch gar nicht gecheckt, wo sie ist und dann musste ich stallen am Card.
Ah ja, aber das war doch nicht schlecht. Es gab viel XP.
Hast du Mario Odyssey gezockt? Ja.
Ne, Donations packen gerade rum. Ich habe gar nicht mitgekriegt, dass du Donatet hast.
Aber ich gucke mal nach. Sevarro hat Donatet. 10 Euro.
Gerade die heise Hauptseite aufgerufen. Im Top-Thema.
Cheating in Fortnite.
Was? Epic zährt 14-jähriges Kind vor Gericht. Mutter läuft Sturm.
Ernsthaft? Die sollen ihre Spiele mal cheatsicher machen, anstatt Kinder zu verklagen.
Vor allem, was will man Cheater verklagen? Ich meine...
Die bieten ja irgendwie... Also die, die irgendwelche Hacks anbieten, kommerziell, okay, verstehe ich, aber...
Weil du kannst... Du kannst die... Na, die haben zwar gegen die Benutzungsbedingungen von dem Spiel verstoßen, aber...
Hä? Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das... Vor allem nicht in Deutschland.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das in Deutschland klappt.
Was ist das überhaupt in Deutschland?
Was ist das Friseurspiel? Das Friseurspiel Black Desert Online.
Hello. Hello.
Pay2Win MMO. Na, ja...
Also wenn man jetzt Pay2Win in ja und dann nein einsortieren müsste, dann ist Black Desert schon bei ja Pay2Win, aber es gibt Schlimmeres.
Es hat schon Pay2Win Aspekte.
Vor allem, wenn man das für das... Nicht das Crafting Material, sondern das, das man weniger Material braucht.
Das ist schon Pay2Win.
Dieser Ball.
Moment, was?
Boah.
Heal mich und dann geht's rein.
Easy Rekt.
Wo ist er hin? Bin ich doof? Wo ist er hin?
Hä?
Manchmal bin ich blind.
Das war bestimmt total obvious, wo er hin ist.
Nein, ticken zu weit links.
Es gibt ein paar Helden, die werde ich nie spielen. Das ist unter anderem Hanzo und Mercy. Es gibt so paar Helden, gegen die habe ich die üblichste Abneigung.
Oh fuck.
ich
oh auto wieder am start
oh der kommt gut
was nix gekillt
sammeln wir mal ein bisschen ult charge
kein heal für dich hanso
trotz weg
weiter pusherin
bioris man bringt auf dem main
war was ich habe sie sind vier zuletzt gespielt
käme aufladen
der tunf ist
ist klar hat sich original gedeckt mit dem radios
bei mir auf mein war 3900 in der letzten season als die playstation zu gemacht
ich habe immer die die fähigkeiten von tunf ist
war fach ich habe schon angefangen zu schießen
anzuhalten
heute nicht mal vorkommen leute
was hat ihn jetzt geheilt
hat wieder aufgeweckt
so jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt
okay das sen überlebt immer also ich meine ich hätte mehr treffen können ja klar da
muss einfach nur einer noch mit auf den sen schießen dann ist er kaputt
ich brauche diese mehle combo muss ich auch ein kriegen
doch das
七
Haltestlorrow ours eits
Prepare to attack.
Select your hero.
Für das Objekt hier. Ich bin enttäuscht Blizzard.
Blitz Acht.
Oder ich mag nicht sagen Fredit, Blitz Tacht.
Ich bin enttäuscht Blitz Acht.
Da muss man jetzt gar nicht rein.
Ich bin so scheiße heute.
Ich bin einfach so schlecht.
Was wieso nicht 4k?
Was 4k?
Ja ich hab mir was sinnloses geholt von Amazon.
Ich muss OP, No Amp Charge spielen, dann geht das.
Ich hab wieder meine Raketen vergessen.
Ah.
Ein Reapsaw.
Auto wieder am Start.
Alles muss man selber machen.
No Panjo.
Haha.
Die war alles halt idiotensicher.
Das mit den Raketen muss ich mir mal in richtig guten, in ordentlichen Streams angucken.
Das macht man bestimmt nicht so beim ranfliegen.
Das macht man bestimmt quasi so vorher zur Hälfte ranfliegen.
Das muss man angucken wie die Pros das mit den Raketen machen auf D.Va.
Na man darf jetzt auf D.Va auch nicht komplizierter machen als es ist.
Da vorne kann dir keiner helfen.
Heal please.
Ich dachte eigentlich da bleibt er stehen, aber nope.
Ja der SSD für den Server.
Ich will die 60GB Intel SSDs raushaben.
Ich hab mir jetzt eine günstige 240GB bestellt.
Schieß mich nicht an please, please anschießen.
Oh ne da kannst du nix machen.
Fahrer, na gut wir haben McQueen, Anna und ich kann da auch was gegen machen.
Also eigentlich dürfte die Fahrer nicht zu all zu viel kommen.
So mag ich das, die Play.
Bis dahin habe ich mich schon geboten.
Auto